the framework is you got to start hot we
got to come out with the most value
possible to stop the scroll so you
imagine people just scrolling up and
down we got to stop the thumb so the way
to do that with information is to just
give the best hook and make it appeal to
the most amount of people so you could
have a very narrow topic like a niche
topic based on your industry or whatever
you're talking about but we need to make
that Niche topic have broad appeal so
that's the best type of hook and that's
kind of the first place to start and
when people say like what's the most
important thing that is the most
important thing because without that you
can't even get into the topic you said
Niche topic broad appeal tell people a
little bit about what you do and how
your content could be almost too Niche
yes but then how you brought in it
correct so I'm in the mortgage real
estate space and probably some of the
most boring subjects you know like
nobody wants to learn about home loans
and finance but they do want to learn
about Financial Freedom they do want to
learn about the solutions that your
product provides so I think a lot of
people talk about the process and that's
great on YouTube but it's almost DOA on
social social because nobody cares about
it unless they're in that Niche they're
not actively searching for that content
so this is Discovery content meaning
like
people are just you're just coming up in
the feed you're coming up in the feed so
it's got to be the most valuable content
possible so for me I took these topics
of mortgage real estate and said hey
what is the thing the customer really
wants they want they want to own a home
they want to build wealth they want to
get rich you know they want to avoid
mistakes so I started to take those
topics and make it with a hook that
would cause someone to uh learn about
how they could make money save money or
avoid a mistake and those three rules
like for my hooks ended up creating
hundreds of hooks and that's how you get
more views that's amazing so the
question for the viewer is what would
have the most broad appeal correct what
would go maybe a little bit wider so
that they could reach new people
and then ultimately how do you create a
poignant hook that will grab attention
and then there's some tactics that I
notice you do in your vertical videos
like the first frame is kind of the
thumbnail yeah and you also have kind of
a text hook what is that best practice
especially for Instagram where you
posted yeah that's a really good point
so obviously we're talking about the the
verbal hook what you say it's the first
line out of your mouth in the beginning
of the video there's also an opportunity
for a written hook that appears in the
middle of the screen your eyes are kind
of drawn to it the video pops up
vertically right in the center of the
screen uh for two to three seconds
you've got a written hook and so that's
kind of like it could be exactly what
you said sometimes that's too many words
so you make us you know abbreviated
version of what you said or like if it's
chopped from this podcast we would make
the hook the written hook what the
Hook's going to be but obviously we
didn't say those words so it could be
what you said or could be just what you
wanted to convey to the viewer now I've
seen the style recently where people are
leaving the hook up for the entire video
and they're just putting it at the top
so that's a trend that we're starting to
see work for some creators but for the
most part you want to have that written
hook up three seconds so people can
visually see it they can hear what
you're talking about and then they
decide to stop scrolling maybe give you
their attention for a few seconds if you
got them hopefully you can keep their
attention two things number one I've had
too much coffee today number two if you
have not seen our free master class yet
you're gonna love it if you're serious
about growing your YouTube channel just
go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour Deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class